do you outline all of your work every
time I do Allen all my work and I think
most screenwriters do but as with
everything in the writing process
there's no like one definite cookie
cutter method that always works great
all the time
so I'm always aware that every new
project is like a new adventure and a
new kind of chaotic mess of the process
of how it turns into whatever it turns
into and so outlining pre-planning
everything has its obvious pros and cons
the cons are that maybe there's a
spontaneity that's lost or a it could go
in some direction that surprised you if
you just sort of free Road and didn't
know where it was going which I think
novelists tend to do and maybe some
screenwriters do that too but the the
pro of outlining is that you have a
solid story structurally and you kind of
figure it all out in a way that's hard
to do when you're in the middle of
writing scenes you know so but I think
screenwriting tends to require that
structure more because one of the
reasons that it gives didn't like novel
writing you can be inside a character's
head and in in screenwriting you're
really describing action the people are
taking what they're physically doing
that we would see and what they're
saying and a lot of the content of the
story is underneath that and in a novel
you can just write that other content
because a lot of its like internal
thoughts not every not every novel has a
lot of internal thoughts but many do
whereas in a screenplay you usually
can't really do that so for the audience
to really understand what's going on in
the story and what it all means and what
people want and feel you have to
construct it in a way that's sort of
like a Rubik's Cube kind of where if you
don't pre-plan it it's like impossible
to solve it it seems like it's probably
not impossible but that's been my
experience in my training so I outline
and I usually recommend that writers do
but some people work better where they
can just jump into scenes at an earlier
part of the process and maybe they
discover things that then later go into
the outline and there's a back-and-forth
there's no one method that I think you
have to do it this one way so you've
seen that where people do their first
draft
and then they maybe put it in the
proverbial drawer and then they go and
they could outline later to see well
it's not that you outline later it's
that you see problems in the script and
then you go back to the outline stage to
try to address those problems and make
it more coherent I mean there are
definitely a lot of writers who are good
at scene writing but not good at
structure and not good at the kind of
architecture of a story and and so and I
have counseled many writers and with
that situation and sometimes they have a
real difficult time taking a step back
to the sort of structure or the like
macro view of their story or even their
concept where they're they're more about
I'm comfortable when I'm writing scenes
and I think most writers are more
comfortable writing scenes especially if
you know roughly what the scenes are
supposed to be are gonna be and you can
just write them it can be harder to go
well let me analyze the story from a
larger perspective but the screenwriters
seem to need to be able to do that and
that usually involves some sort of
outlying and pre-planning that you
actually write down before you jump into
the actual script document did you
outline for your book I did outline for
my book yes and so how was that for you
because I know you you you've write a
blog I don't know if your blog came it
definitely it came before the book
obviously so are you taking you know
prior blog posts and plugging them in as
chapters yeah there is some material
from prior blog posts yes where but then
I came up with this sort of
superstructure for the book as a concept
which is that it's going to be these
seven elements and each one has its own
chapter and then I might have had some
material on my blog from years ago that
fit that if I repurposed and revised it
somewhat and then also writing some new
material as well
you